[Music]
Howdy Folks this is Coleman Alderson for
Gardens all.com and today I'm here to
share with you our Harvest of our
Romanian red garlic and we'll put up
some information on that in an article
pertaining to harvesting garlic it's a
perfect time this is May 20th
thereabouts and um
we just pulled this one out of the
ground I wanted to show you a little bit
of its uh Anatomy of course you have the
garlic bulb here this is a Romanian red
variety by the way rather spicy well
known for its intense flavor and its its
heat it's uh it's good in a lot of
dishes and we'll be posting some recipes
on how to use it but we have the uh the
bulb we have the roots down here nice
healthy set of roots these were set out
in November
went through the winter just fine and
now we have this we have a hard neck
right here it's the hard neck garlic and
what's really interesting is these um
these leaves you have just regular flat
sort of leaves and then as the season
rolls on and gets warmer you get the
these things called
escapes and this is a kind of a
snake-like thing that comes up it's
different than the regular leaves it's
it's like part of the stem actually and
um this is an especially long one but
Scapes are great they're one of the
first things you can go ahead and cut
off your plant before you even pull it
out of the ground and take it in and use
it in all kinds of recipes that we'll
tell you about
but that's part of the the curing
process I'll be cutting the scape off
and then hanging this up to
cure for two weeks or so in the shade
it's real important you don't lay it out
in the sun but nice
airflow and nice shade so it isn't
exposed to the Sun and you don't have to
clean it off very much just let it
dangle there and we use a fence
basically
a plastic fence that we used to use to
keep the dogs out of the garden but uh
it works really well we put on a slight
frame so it will hold its position and
then we hang it up under the eaves of
some of our buildings here and it works
really good drives them out and in about
two weeks they'll be ready to trim up
take inside
so this is Coleman Alderson for
gardensall.com I hope you all are having
fun if you're planting garlic yourselves
let us know write in your comments on
our channel here subscribe to us if you
will and also check out our alert by
hitting that little bell up there and we
will be sending you all kinds of updates
on what's happening but especially if
you had some great experiences or maybe
not so great experiences in growing
garlic we'd love to hear from you
that's it Coleman Alderson for gardens
all.com
thank you
Howdy Folks I'm back with you here in
our Shady location under an eve of one
of our storage buildings and what I
constructed here was a very simple frame
using this kind of plastic fencing that
is stretched across a rectangular frame
and then hung from inside the eaves here
and this is an ideal location you got
good airflow we have nice shade sun is
barely ever even touching this area and
um
it'll take about two weeks
to to have this cure out right so I want
to show you what what we do here with
each
plant
first thing I'm going to do is cut out
this scape
which is a kind of a serpentine like
creature that grows
in the uh within the leaves usually
coming out near the top of the garlic
plant and you can cut these before you
even harvest the plants they're really
delicious you can think of them in terms
of stir fry and mixing them in with
flavoring anything that you might use a
green onion for it has a little bit
extra zap because it is a garlic flavor
so similar to The Garlic chives but
because this is a Romanian red it has a
a quality about it that is kind of spicy
so
that's the first thing we do
and then we want to weave
this top part of the plant into
the fabric of the fence picking out
one of the squares to push the leaves up
through and try to weave it up through
it
and to make it easier
what we can do is
start at the top and just do a little
fold here
and there's no science to this I'm just
picking in our arbitrary spot here
and then kind of meshing it up together
so it will go through the um
through the grid here
and then you just take it
and start at a place where you want your
bulb to hang somewhere
within the frame if you can
these are tough leaves but I'm weaving
them through the uh I'm going to go
every other Square
the better that way and then kind of
push it up through
see how this is working here
and we'll go up through here again
and after you get through about two of
these you really don't have to worry
about doing it
much more it'll it'll take care of
itself
okay all right
so
we have our garlic push up a little more
or a garlic bulb hanging here and the
leaves will feed a little bit more
nutrition to it and as it cures out
in two weeks it'll be ready to go
here's the old stem from
from the uh
Escape
kind of tough
okay
and then you can trim it up
but we'll be back here in two weeks
to check it out
and here we have a completed panel of
our garlic
curing now for 14 days
thanks very much for watching folks
Coleman Alderson for gardensall.com
[Music]